power rankings are posted every tuesday
at noon time eastern or thereabouts and
on wednesday we discuss them and a
shakeup even though the saints won the
seahawks one and the packers won they
all dropped by one because the big move
king me 49ers jumping everybody up to
the top to number two not number one i
wasn't crazy i wasn't going to put them
in front of the patriots but they're
close chris they got him and you've you
had and look you've influenced me
because you've always said pretty much
every week the 49ers are too low the
49ers are too low and i thought you were
just you know doing a favor for your
friend kyle shanahan but after what they
did to the rams i could no longer deny
it and none of the other wins for the
three teams that were in front of them
were nearly as impressive to have short
week against a team that had extra days
and extra motivation and desperation
time to go in and beat them the way they
did 49ers go to number two i didn't give
serious consideration about making them
number one because i think if you're
number one you gotta lose i can't lose
that spot but but they're right there
they they are right there uh and again i
i didn't pick the 49ers to go to the
playoffs i mean you know what a bad
friend i am but i was scared about jimmy
garoppolo really and maybe the jury's
still out a little bit on garoppolo uh
because he hasn't really had to have
that moment yet where he's gonna carry
the team the defense the run game
everything's been somewhat easy for him
as far as that's concerned but mike i
give you credit man way to go because i
think they're clearly are the second
best team and i you know yeah for the
last two three weeks uh i i know i've
been trying to say like the the 49ers
are going to be in this first round buy
conversation they're that good they're
not going anywhere they're not they got
13 and 3 12 and 4 maybe even better
written all over themselves right now
and i'm with you i think they are in a
little bit of their own cream of the
crop with just them and the patriots and
you know you think of the patriots you
go well they haven't really played
anybody yet and you can look at the san
francisco 49ers and go up they've played
people you know the browns aren't
slouches i mean they did go to baltimore
and like whoop the baltimore ravens you
know they beat the rams last week on the
road the steelers yes i mean they were a
pain in the butt that game the
buccaneers early on in the year i mean
we've seen that they got a little
potential so the 49ers have done
everything to prove us that they deserve
to be your number two team good job got
you michael james florio now here's the
thing after the 49ers yeah right well
after the patriots rather the top afc
team you've got four nfc teams and i
think that that that kind of fits our
perception i think the difference
between the afc and the nfc patriots far
and away the best team in the afc i
don't know who the second best team is
but you know who it is in the power
rankings
buffalo bills number six behind those
four nfc teams they moved up two spots
without playing chris the ravens jump up
to number seven they now have marcus
peters i don't know whether that puts
them in the conversation to be the
second best team in the afc do you think
that makes them the second best team in
the afc having peters no i don't i'm not
gonna throw that out there yet i do
think it will help their team it's a
bold move they didn't give up a ton
to take a chance on a guy that certainly
has talent maybe not been as good the
last two years as we'd like him to be
but he is still really good he fits the
attitude of that baltimore ravens team
and i think the big thing they did there
is we can't rush to passer we're a slow
team we need our slow defense especially
we need our corners aka peters and
marlon humphrey uh and brandon carr and
maybe jimmy smith when they get back
they're gonna have to play some
man-to-man and we're gonna have to be
creative with the other other guys on
the back end but good for you with the
bills too mike way to go because the
bills their defense is phenomenal as
you've said and i don't think we've seen
the best from their offense yet either i
mean they're winning with josh allen
making
a bonehead or or two mistakes every game
and i think that's really encouraging
for buffalo because the kid's smart he's
gonna figure this out and how to reign
it in at some point we know he's got
talent and when they kind of all get
that all together you know watch out for
buffalo in the afc
quick summary then of the top ten for
the radio crowd patriots won 49ers two
saints three seahawks four packers five
we mentioned the bills at six ravens
seven texans up to number eight after
beating the chiefs who fall to number
nine yup panthers at number 10 at four
and two just outside the top ten a team
that i had outside of the top 20 a
couple of weeks ago but they've won two
in a row they're now number 11 in the
minnesota yeah
baby
you didn't want to i like though that
you did not want to put them in the top
ten were you what how close was it
between the vikings and the panthers
there to make you go uh which way there
what was the deciding factor of putting
the panthers at 10 and making the
vikings 11.
i the panthers are on a four-game
winning streak and i i think that the
vikings at detroit this weekend is where
the two-game winning streak is likely to
end but if they beat the lions this
weekend then i'm gonna have to
reevaluate my thoughts on all of this uh
on whether or not they're gonna be seven
and seven after 14 games going into
packers bears at home for a playoff
berth maybe they will be better than
that maybe they will be closing in on
that playoff berth when they when they
host the packers a couple of days before
christmas on monday night football but
uh yeah
look it's they still have to win a game
they're not supposed to win before i'm
going to be a believer and i think this
weekend at detroit i don't know what the
point spread is it feels like a game
they're not supposed to win and the
lions are going to be extra salty after
what happened on monday night i got the
rams at number 12. they fell five spots
from number seven the cowboys at number
13. they're down four from number nine
eagles at 14 eagles and cowboys get
together this week bears are at 15. they
were in that three weeks
right here seriously did you mess up how
did i mess up how well the raiders just
like dominated the bears and you put
them a spot below like that's how you
messed up that's how i had it last week
though i had the three-way tie oh i
flipped the two okay flip the two
it doesn't matter at least you got away
from that tie i mean that stupid tie you
had last week oh my gosh that was one of
the worst power ranking flubs of all
time that i've ever seen no it wasn't it
made absolute sense it was logical it
was sensible and and i take your scorn
as a badge of honor all right uh the
colts at 17 they were unchanged line's
down to 18. steelers up from 24 to 19.
there's a bunch of two and four teams
you know there's there's a lot there's
too many two and four teams or worse and
uh and then down at the bottom the
dolphins are back in 32 after losing to
the previous number 32 team washington
dolphins own the 30-second spot i have a
feeling they're going to be there for
the rest of the
2019 season although i think they play
the bengals at some point that may end
up being the tank for two bowl shows get
together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports